son muchos los acontecimientos que
tienen lugar en una semana en el mundo
por eso tenemos este espacio para
analizar y para conversar sobre los
temas más destacados de los últimos
cinco días bienvenidos esto es una
semana en el mundo para conversar sobre
los temas que tenemos en la agenda para
el día de hoy hemos invitado a Jairo
libreros periodista editor analista
político y analista Internacional de la
cadena
ntn24 se encuentra aquí en el estudio
con mi amigo Jairo bienvenido un gusto
tenerlo aquí con nosotros cómo termina
su semana Santiago Muchas gracias por la
invitación es muy importante compartir
para mi espacio como lo hicimos hace ya
muchos años las hermanas yo creo que
termina eléctrica es difícil encontrar
una afirmación diferente lo que pasó
hace ocho días y los efectos de la
llegada de Lula y por tercera ocasión a
palacio plan alto yo creo que marca una
Pauta en América Latina muy importante
tenemos el estrés de lo que viene la
otra semana con las elecciones de medio
término en Estados en Estados Unidos
y hay dos temas que creo que vale la
pena trabajar por lo menos el caso
colombiano
aprobado una reforma tributaria muy dura
muy encaminada hacia la clase media que
es lo más fácil para tributar no por lo
menos del punto de vista del estado y un
viaje de Petro va para Egipto y para
París o sea es una semana bastante
movida importante como muchos temas en
la agenda hace más o menos una década
que no trabajábamos en conjunto no
compartíamos un espacio
más o menos pero bueno aquí tenemos el
gusto para poder conversar de diferentes
temas de la actualidad internacional
también está con nosotros Ángel sastre
él es periodista fue corresponsal por
cerca de 17 años en la región de América
Latina y ahora trabaja en una novela
gráfica cómic con el material que ha
recopilado a lo largo de estos años de
cobertura en Venezuela 15 años estuvo
allí en Venezuela y ahora con ese
material entonces pues está con este
nuevo proyecto bienvenido Ángel y cué
cómo termina su semana
bueno termina bastante bien Yo cuando
termina la semana ya estoy pensando la
siguiente Así que bastante relajado
bastante bien Y preparando nuevos
proyectos y ya la agenda yo la verdad
que soy un poco el fin de semana también
trabajo pero bien muy bien somos varios
los periodistas que nos toca trabajar el
fin de semana Ahora le doy la bienvenida
a Héctor estepa él es periodista
freelance para la región de América
Latina también nos acompaña hoy en el
programa Héctor bienvenido cuéntenos
también cómo termina estos cinco días
Muchos temas sobre la mesa
Hola buenas tardes pues ha sido una
semana es bastante complicada aquí en
Brasil
Lula da Silva ganó la selecciones por un
margen muy estrecho y Los Seguidores del
bolsonaron han estado en la calle
Durante los últimos cinco días pidiendo
incluso una intervención militar hemos
estado en las calles relatando esos
momentos de tensión que parece eso sí
que ya se han apaciguado en las últimas
horas también los invito para que
ustedes nos acompañen con todos los
comentarios y preguntas que tengan sobre
los temas que vamos a tratar a lo largo
del programa a través de nuestras redes
sociales arroba
france24_es@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta es numeral una
semana en el mundo f24 todo junto para
que dejen ahí sus comentarios comenzamos
Entonces porque la agenda está larga
está extensa para para el programa de
hoy ya lo estamos mencionando Brasil ha
estado en el foco de la prensa
internacional en los últimos días
podríamos decir por tres aspectos muy
puntuales ya vamos a conversarlo aquí
con los invitados si se puede
profundizar un poco más sobre estos
temas el primero pues es el triunfo de
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva en estas
elecciones presidenciales lo que le
garantiza entonces poder gobernar Brasil
por tercera vez dos también podemos
decir ese ajustado resultado que
mencionaba Héctor Hace algunos minutos
un ajustado resultado en estos comicios
Lula no ganó tan cómodamente como creían
y Yair bolsonaro pues se puede decir que
se le escapó la reelección por un 1,8%
de diferencia y el tercer punto que
también queda ahí para destacar es la
demora de bolsonaro en dar una
declaración a la nación y también la
incertidumbre que generó sobre el
resultado de las elecciones también hay
que hablar de esas manifestaciones
ciudadanas en algunos puntos o en por lo
menos en las principales ciudades de
Brasil comenzamos entonces con este tema
le doy entonces la palabra a Héctor para
comenzar la ronda la inversa Héctor este
tema usted esperaba El Triunfo de Lula
da Silva muchos lo veían muy claro desde
el inicio de la campaña la verdad yo
debo decir eh A mí me mantuvo en
incertidumbre hasta el último voto y
hasta el último porcentaje entregado por
el tsb
El Triunfo de Lula era previsible según
lo que nos decían las encuestas Pues en
los últimos meses qué es lo que ha
ocurrido que Lula finalmente ha ganado
pero no ha ganado por un margen tan
amplio como el que se predecía como el
que predecían las encuestas hace apenas
un mes le daban incluso encuestas muy
reputadas aquí en Brasil más de 15
puntos de venta de ventaja sobre Jair
bolsonaro eso no ha ocurrido las
encuestas se han equivocado aquí al
final la diferencia ha sido de alrededor
de 2 millones de votos que algo muy
pequeño aquí en un país que tiene más de
160 millones de lectores y por 1,4
puntos
que provocan o que de alguna manera
empoderan ese discurso de bolsonaro de
que pues las encuestadoras están contra
él que el sistema está en contra de él
esto también ha provocado que algunas
personas salieran a la calle provocando
fraude electoral bolsonaro estuvo
durante años criticando el sistema
electrónico de votación de Brasil No hay
ninguna prueba ni ha habido ninguna
prueba en estos 25 años lo que el
sistema lleva vigente de fraude pero
después de que evolucionaron criticarse
con tanta fuerza las encuestadoras y
señalarse este sistema como posiblemente
fraudulento ese Esa diferencia tan corta
pues ha provocado también que muchos
fallecen a la calle Ángel su opinión
viajaba muchas veces a Brasil muchas
elecciones he estado con el compañero
Héctor
he visto a salir elegido muchas veces yo
veo que hay un estrecho margen que nadie
se esperaba y quizás haya sido un voto
de castigo hacia la corrupción pasado
los escándalos de corrupción pasada y al
mismo tiempo si bien es cierto que
bolsonaro ha tardado en aparecer no ha
tenido ese discurso transgresor y
radical de otras de otras veces es decir
quizás el mismo se esté dando cuenta de
que tenga posibilidades si suaviza su
discurso de ganar a todos esos votantes
que sorpresivamente han ido en contra de
Lula por eso no ha rechazado
radicalmente pese a ver en un principio
haber negado las encuestas y yo diría
que de ahora en adelante quizás
encontremos a un bolsonaron más
apaciguado más apaciguado Ya lo vamos a
ver desde ese punto de vista aquí en el
estudio Jairo yo me quedo con dos
palabras una dentro y otra de ángel que
creo que son muy importantes cuando se
acaba la serie o se acaba el proceso
electoral sin duda tenemos unas lecturas
compartidas pero yo tengo una lectura
que me preocupa mucho el crecimiento de
la votación especialmente la votación
cristiana o evangélica dicen algunos es
una crecimiento creo que
proporcionalmente inusitado en América
Latina muy seguramente ellos en el corto
plazo van a tener la posibilidad de
formular coaliciones que lleven a una
mayoría en el congreso o en algunas
gobernaciones importantes y hasta poner
presidente ese es un punto que creo que
este vive en toda la región pero con
mucha fuerza en Brasil es más alcancé a
ver a Lula no sé si mis compañeros me
pueden corregir Lula en algunas
reuniones con organizaciones o iglesias
católicas y de otra y de otra membresía
dos
bolsonaro pierde pero hay que tener en
cuenta que si hay un giro muy fuerte
hacia la derecha en Brasil eso es un
tema que es respetable es entendible
creo que todos tenemos la capacidad de
ser lo suficientemente pluralistas para
entender cómo se mueve El péndulo no
solamente los candidatos sino los
electores pero es un movimiento de la
derecha casi que radical vimos ayer o
Antier movimientos radicales casi que
extremistas no he podido verificar mucha
información pero hasta hubo escenas no
sé si fueron manipuladas en donde daban
a entender ciertos gestos vinculados con
con temas que nosotros creímos que en
Europa estaban sepultados desde el final
de la Segunda Guerra Mundial y yo creo
que esta elección nos deja muchas cosas
indudablemente la diferencia corta entre
el hule y bolsonaro lo difícil que va a
ser administrar un movimiento hacia la
derecha pero creo que la región más
temprano que tarde va a volver a una
situación en donde la derecha extrema va
a jugar un papel muy importante y en
cierta medida yo un ángel esa prudencia
evolucionario Aún demorándose es
pensando y respetando las diferencias
con Trump lo que muy Seguramente se
puede esperar Trump creo que se lanza el
martes
bolsonaro va a seguir Atentamente ese
proceso y estoy seguro que bolsonaro en
el 2026 2027 puede volver a ser
presidente de Brasil todas las opciones
están sobre la mesa Hablemos del
comportamiento de bolsonaro generó
muchísima controversia a nivel
internacional se especuló de todas las
formas posible que estaba buscando como
acercarse a los militares para que
salieran a las calles que se estaba
escapando a los emiratos árabes que que
iba a salir en una declaración a
medianoche que al otro día o sea hubo
todo tipo de desinformación como también
lo a lo largo de la campaña a través de
las redes sociales Pero cómo interpreta
uno ese comportamiento del presidente
bolsonaro y también él les extende un
poquito más la pregunta para comenzar
con Héctor que fue el que puso sobre la
mesa
el término de apaciguar si tal vez ahora
con la presidencia de Lula que empieza a
partir del primero de enero puede volver
un poco más la cordura a al gobierno de
Brasil y dejar todas estas controversias
que rodearon a bolsonaro a lo largo de
estos cuatro años
Bueno sobre Por qué bolsonaro habló tan
tarde se ha especulado muchísimo aquí en
Brasil se filtró a la prensa que algunos
de sus más cercanos ministros de sus más
cercanos colaboradores casi que le
pidieron de rodillas que por favor
decretarse la victoria de Lula o
reconociese la victoria de Lula y
aceptarse su derrota mientras que otro
miembro más
dogmático del ejecutivo le pedían lo
contrario lo que sí que coincide en la
mayoría de los analistas que esto fue un
cálculo político efectivamente como
apuntaba Jairo antes pensando en 2026 es
decir el presidente ya está pensando en
volver a las urna en 2026 sabe que su
movimiento de derecha que ha creado aquí
en Brasil es muy fuerte de hecho el
conservadurismo en mayoría en el
congreso en el que también su partido el
partido bolsonaro tiene una gran fuerza
y está pensando en 2026 Entonces el
cálculo político de bolsonaro creen
parte de los analistas aquí en Brasil
con respecto comportamiento esta semana
era si yo no acepto el resultado de las
elecciones voy a perder votos por el
centro y si yo lo acepto sin rechistar
voy a perder votos de mis seguidores
digamos más radicales o más dogmáticos
eso fue un cálculo político del
presidente y con respecto a la otra
pregunta con respecto si se van a
apaciguar las cosas aquí en Brasil eso
dependerá mucho de cómo vaya a gobernar
Lula
en si Lula se mueve como parece que se
está moviendo un poco más hacia el
centro viendo la alianzas que ha hecho
con políticos de Centro como el que va a
ser vicepresidente como Gerardo
almínguez recordemos fue de hecho su
máximo rival en las elecciones de 2006 Y
que ahora ha sido además nombrado como
jefe del equipo de transición de Lula si
Lula consigue moverse al centro va a
apaciguar un poco yo creo el la
temperatura aquí en Brasil pero hay que
recordar que bolsonaro quiere volver en
2026 que tiene buena parte del apoyo en
el congreso y también dependerá de cómo
se comporten esos partidos bisagras en
el congreso si se participa la situación
o no Jairo por acá para hacer la ronda
la inversa ya le doy la palabra Ángel
muy interesante Estoy totalmente de
acuerdo con Héctor y quisiera agregar
algo
Brasil como pase muchas democracias en
América Latina se respira un descontento
popular muy grande contra la democracia
quizás los primeros síntomas de ese
malestar social se vieron en Brasil en
la época de Gilmar russef Lula apoyado
también por Fernando Cardozo sacaron
28-30 millones de personas de la pobreza
la llevan a la clase media y ese primer
laboratorio de esa clase media que dijo
Ok nos educamos nos alimentamos mejor
tenemos empleo pero ya no podemos subir
y viene la crisis y empiezan a perder
puestos si él no logra tener un manejo
muy rápido en el primer trimestre del
próximo año de enviar mensajes y dar
respuestas sociales Yo creo que el
apaciguamiento creo en lo que dice
Héctor se puede resquebrajar aquí hay
que dar respuesta de política pública la
democracia representativa no lo están
haciendo Y si él no logra entregar
respuestas positivas para calmar el
malestar para fortalecer ciertos
sectores para darle nuevamente aliento a
un proyecto de vida distinto que no sea
la pobreza yo creo que va a tener muchas
dificultades y la única forma como dice
Héctor es yendo hacia el centro
mejorando sus alianzas identificando
partidos bisagras que le permita una
mejor interlocución con diferentes
sectores no solamente Con quienes sufren
el malestar social sino con sectores
empresariales que ven con muchas
confianza la llegada de Lula y creo que
si él se mantiene en el centro Lo va a
lograr pero la espada de damocles de él
es no calmar el descontento popular que
es muy fuerte en Brasil que lleva muchos
años sintiéndose y que evolucionaron no
logró manejar no logró manejar pero pero
sí son dos brasiles Completamente
divididos de acuerdo a los resultados y
tiene que ponerle a los a las dos caras
de la moneda Ángel su opinión para ir
cerrando este tema yo creo que vamos a
ver cómo van los candidatos se van
acercando por lo menos en esta primera
fase hacia el centro de la izquierda
hacia el centro de una manera más
pragmática de nuevo dando ayudas
sociales intentando Bueno pues el sello
No del PP y de Lula da Silva pero
también contentando a los empresarios y
siguiendo esa línea más pragmática que
tenía bolsonaro y bolsonaro también por
lo menos al principio se va a explorar
hacia el centro va como decía antes o
apaciguar o suavizar ese discurso pero
yo creo que según se acerquen las nuevas
elecciones veremos según vaya esta
legislación veremos Cómo ambas partes
vuelven a su sitio y vuelven a
enamorarlos los discursos de izquierda y
de derecha algo que me gusta el formato
de este programa es que me da la
oportunidad de salirme un poco de la
rigidez de los informativos y el
programa de debate para poner sobre en
la mesa un poco más de especulación pero
también viene argumentado y ustedes
hablaban de bolsonar o siguiendo los
pasos de lo que está haciendo Donald
Trump No sé ustedes como ven ángel
continuó con usted para hacer la ronda
la inversa si hay otros presidentes
otros políticos de la región de América
Latina mirando Atentamente lo que está
pasando en Brasil para hacer lo mismo en
un futuro en sus respectivos países y
quienes podrían ser
por supuesto tenemos todo lo que es el
eje que se ha creado de izquierdas ahora
mismo tenemos todo lo que es Bolivia
Tenemos también por supuesto Argentina
tenemos Brasil y Venezuela de nuevo
siempre hace ya casi dos décadas que hay
una lucha entre la derecha y la
izquierda que se va tenemos Alberto
Fernández que hay un discurso que
también el mismo
está ahora intentando centralizar y
separarse siempre con esa disputa que
tiene con Cristina kirchner y también
Incluso en Bolivia hemos visto como ya
no se usa un discurso tan extremista
como el que tenía No extremista tan
escorado a la izquierda como el que
tenía Evo Morales estamos viendo de
nuevo reitero la palabra candidatos que
si bien son de izquierdas maduro
directamente es que ha desaparecido de
la órbita informativa entre otras cosas
por Ucrania pero sí que vemos que todo
este eje nuevo de la izquierda estos
líderes buscan esco más al centro Jairo
por acá dos cosas voy Un paso atrás yo
creo que hombres como Trump o bolsonaro
siguieron Atentamente lo que ocurría en
Europa con Urban lo que acaba de pasar
con melón en Italia el ascenso de la
derecha radical en Suecia lo que está
pasando con el partido político vox en
España y creo que han sacado las mejores
lecciones aprendidas para quedarse con
un descontento popular con discursos
autoritarios para llegar al poder y
desmontar tranquilamente cierto tipo de
instituciones desde ese punto de vista
tener 11 gobiernos con bandera de
izquierda o la ola rosa para
diferenciarla de lo que fue a comienzo
de este siglo el socialismo del Siglo 21
va a generar unos nuevos liderazgos o
consolidará nuevos liderazgos en materia
derecha tratando de seguir los patrones
de bolsonaro y los patrones de Trump yo
no creo que en Argentina por citar un
caso el señor macri vaya a utilizar esos
mismos mecanismos Pero él también sabe
que más temprano tarde si quiere darle
viabilidad a una segunda candidatura va
a tener que utilizarlo lo que estamos
viendo en Bolivia lo que está pasando en
Perú donde también con Arce hay
problemas ya pero como Castillo en Perú
la situación es mucho más críticas
fujimori va a volver y va a volver con
un discurso Mucho más duro la última
etapa de su candidatura le sirvió pero
se demoró mucho en ser radical entonces
El péndulo va a cambiar el problema es
que el patrón a seguir es el estilo de
bolsonaro o el estilo de Trump Y eso sí
va a ser muy difícil de procesar en toda
la región es difícil para cerrar este
tema rápidamente Héctor muy puntual por
favor estoy de acuerdo estoy de acuerdo
con Jairo pienso que va a ser muy
importante lo que ocurre tanto en estas
elecciones de medio término en Estados
Unidos como en la futuras elecciones
presidenciales de Estados Unidos quiero
decir ahora lo que mira la derecha dura
continental de América Latina es si
Donald Trump una vez después de salir
del poder va a volver a alcanzar la
presidencia o no y eso seguro que va a
marcar el futuro de esos movimientos en
el resto del continente
dejamos este tema por acá obviamente
mucho para conversar sobre el tema de
las elecciones y de política brasileña
pero avanzamos con otro tema y es esa
visita del presidente de Colombia
Gustavo Petro a Nicolás Maduro en la
ciudad de Caracas por fin Se tomaron esa
foto que no se habían tomado en la
frontera Ahora sí se la tomaron en el
Palacio de Miraflores en la capital
venezolana ahí también muchísimas
especulación que Venezuela está haciendo
uso de Colombia para poder volver a la
cena internacional Colombia haciendo uso
de las necesidades económicas de
Venezuela para poder
impulsar la economía a través de la
exportación a Venezuela también se habla
muchísimos temas a nivel de migración y
a nivel político Jairo su balance de
esta de Esta visita le Confieso que me
encantó Hubo mucho estrés y muchas
críticas en contra de Gustavo Petro
porque se iba a sentar con una persona
que considerada en algunos sectores como
un dictador violador de los derechos
humanos y causante de una crisis
humanitaria nunca antes vista por lo
menos en la historia contemporánea en
América Latina pero creo que maneja un
discurso muy interesante habló de
democracia liberal dijo algo que yo
comparto íntimamente en términos
ideológicos
confirmar que un país es una democracia
liberal es aceptar los Derechos Humanos
especialmente la convención americana
sobre Derechos Humanos esto no va a ser
fácil pero también está claro que les
vio muchos mensajes Si quieres sacar
adelante su paz total sentarse a
negociar con el Ln y con las dos
disidencias de La FARC tiene que ser
amigo del inquilino Miraflores porque
los actores están en Venezuela son 37
campamentos identificados en la frontera
especialmente en el estado de zulia ese
punto sale muy bien dos que no podemos
olvidar Petro tiene una apuesta
latinoamericana tenemos reunión el
segundo viernes en Buenos Aires de
diciembre de la celac muy seguramente
Petro con esta reunión aseguró y con el
triunfo de seguro de traerse la
presidencia protempole de la celac un
organismo que para algunas personas no
juega un papel importante pero es que
ninguno Lo juega en América Latina la
oea no tiene movilidad Claro pero con
Petro va a ser a otro precio y cierro
con esto muy puntual si uno se atiende a
los estudios hay tres muy buenos en
Colombia se desarrolla uno del externado
y otro los Andes si sale viendo la
frontera este año tenemos que sumarle al
crecimiento del pib por lo menos
0,5%. al 20 25 le sumamos dos y si sale
todo bien no no espectacular bien
Colombia va a crecer Tres puntos
porcentuales por el comercio en
Venezuela eso implica que en el 2026
Colombia solamente va a crecer por
Venezuela porque el promedio proyectado
por el Banco Mundial es del otro año es
crecer 0,5% y en el 26 crecer uno por
ciento es una apuesta Ángel su opinión
esa historia del amor y Odio que llevan
tiempos desde Hugo Chávez Uribe Santos
la frontera es un tema clave tenemos no
solo táchira Cúcuta tenemos la selva
tenemos ya bueno la extinta entre
comillas FARC y Tenemos también los
campamentos de la lln el narcotráfico
como ha servido de Refugio pero también
la migración o el otro desierto la
guajira el desierto del hambre donde
están los guayuros indígenas que también
sufren graves problemas como la
desnutrición pero sobre todo yo diría
estos temas no también el tema económico
y de la migración les conviene llevarse
bien entre comillas y no tener las
disputas anteriores que han tenido que
han sido unos resquemores muy fuertes Yo
creo que es una es una relación de
conveniencia tendrán que tener en cuenta
sobre todo la de estas horas migratorias
que ha habido hacia Colombia la gente
que tiene menos recursos de Venezuela
utilizados los países limítrofes y creo
que es un paso adelante no no va a
cambiar ninguno de los dos gobiernos su
posturas y que les conviene llevarse
bien
pasamos ahora a preguntarle a Héctor
sobre este tema
Yo estoy de acuerdo tanto con Jairo como
con Ángel pienso que es muy importante
atender a los gestos
Petro dijo en campaña electoral varias
veces se ha referido varias veces a
maduro como dictador entonces por eso
sorprendió tanto por lo menos a mí me
sorprendió la postura con la que el
embajador colombiano en Venezuela
Benedetti Una vez que se reanudaron en
las relaciones entre ambos países llegó
a Caracas en una actitud jovial verdad y
y abrazándose allí Pues con con todos
los líderes de Venezuela Petro no ha
hecho eso Petro ha llegado de una manera
Digamos como más Serena más de jefe de
estado mucho más sobria a reunirse con
maduro efectivamente Como Dice Jairo
nombró la democracia liberal y también
dijo en la rueda de prensa que quería
que Venezuela volviese al sistema
interamericano de derecho humano lo cual
supondría acatar las decisiones de la
corte y pues un avance hacia la
democratización de Venezuela o hacer que
los líderes tomen en medidas
democráticas Entonces tenemos
dos intenciones por un lado Petro parece
dispuesto o parece creer que puede
mediar en el proceso que llevaría una
apertura democrática de Venezuela
También necesita como apuntado Jairo a
Venezuela para conseguir su paz Total
recordemos que parte de la comandancia
tanto del ejército de liberación
Nacional del Ln como de la segunda
marquetalia se encuentra en Venezuela de
hecho Iván Márquez el líder de la
segunda marquetalia se encuentra en un
hospital venezolano y también necesita
al país para tener una mayor
Independencia en el tema de
fertilizantes que está muy afectado con
la guerra de Rusia y otros y también en
otras cuestiones de índole política y
económica maduro por su parte necesita
Colombia para de alguna manera dejar de
estar aislado y el legitimarse parece
que Petro no está tan dispuesto a dejar
legitimarse maduro sin conseguir de
forma demo veremos cómo avanza eso será
clave de nuevo la próxima reunión que
tenga el gobierno venezolano con
miembros de la oposición que se va a
celebrar parece dentro de muy poquito
Ángel pero maduro sí estará dispuesto a
dar esos pasos hacia pasos democráticos
para poder
mostrarse un poco más afianzado a nivel
internacional recuperar un poco Esa esa
imagen que ha perdido a lo largo de los
años que piensa usted
no yo pienso que lo que va a hacer
Nicolás Maduro es ya tiene prácticamente
costados todos los poderes el tribunal
supremo esto ha sido ha sido paso lento
pero vamos lo he ido cocinando bien en
el sentido en que ya tiene el supremo
controlado tiene el ejército controlado
el Consejo Nacional electoral controlado
y la oposición por lo que parece después
de las de las protestas del 2017 la
oposición también ha quedado muy mermada
yo creo que Sencillamente todavía quedan
hasta el 2025 las elecciones va a tomar
una postura la hasta ahora
va a seguir con el mismo discurso un
discurso no no tan no tan escorado no
tan bolivariano quizás más moderado pero
yo no creo que vaya a tomar grandes ya
puesto todas las fichas en su sitio
quiero decir las elecciones no va a
haber grandes cambios porque tú has ido
colocando durante estos años para que
todo funcione y las reglas del juego
sean como él quiere
algo que me llama la atención y que lo
está mencionando Ángel la oposición En
dónde quedó en toda esta foto de esta
película no quedó en ese momento los
grandes cuestionamientos que hay en
Venezuela es el papel que jugó Juan
guaidó que termina haciendo
instrumentalizado por Duque por el
presidente de los colombianos que se
inventó el cerco diplomático que resultó
ser un fracaso pensaban que con un
concierto internacional y metiendo
camiones a la brava por la frontera en
febrero el año 2019 Pues iba a derrumbar
en Miraflores es más recuerda algo dijo
Duque en aquella ocasión le quedan pocas
horas al dictador de Venezuela pasa
horas pasaron los días la semana los
meses y los años
la oposición yo creo que una de las
ejemplos más críticos que tenemos
contemporáneamente en América Latina de
una oposición errática que no logró
construir un discurso lo suficientemente
claro y preciso para atraer votantes y
mostrarse una manera diferente en la
venezolana está como con cinco o seis
líderes hoy sector muy importante que no
quiere saber nada de la oposición nada
de capriles no quiere saber nada de
María Corina no quiere saber nada de
Juan guaidó no quiere saber nada de
Leopoldo López Yo creo que es el momento
para que maduro apueste por unas
elecciones y cierro con esto Si Tú lees
con delicadeza el comunicado del
departamento de la Casa Blanca
felicitando a Lula utilizó un término
que yo no escuchaba hacía muchos años la
mejor forma de llegar al poder es
garantizar la democracias de origen la
legitimidad de origen de la democracias
ese mensaje no era para Brasil porque es
que por elecciones Lula nunca ha sido
dictador bolsonaro tampoco y creo que
ese tema va a tener que ser leído muy
bien por Miraflores justamente Jairo
menciona a Estados Unidos quiero que
calentemos motores porque la próxima
semana vamos a estar hablando de las
elecciones de medio término en Estados
Unidos muy importantes para el
presidente biden muy importante para la
democracia estadounidense muy importante
también para el ex presidente Donald
Trump y para los republicanos los dejo
para libre comentario
Comencemos entonces con Héctor sobre
este tema que se viene para para la
próxima semana que seguramente vamos a
estar analizando en todos los medios
internacionales
Pues si las elecciones de medio término
en Estados Unidos son importantes todos
los años este año en el contexto de la
Guerra de Ucrania muchísimo más son unas
elecciones que recordemos siempre suelen
perjudicar al partido que está en el
gobierno de hecho la previsión más
plausible es que los demócratas pierdan
la cámara de representantes que se
renueva totalmente está por ver si
perderán o no el senado y de eso
dependerá el posterior análisis
Obviamente si lo demócratas pierden las
dos cámaras Además de que va yden tendrá
que comenzar a operar más por órdenes
ejecutivas pues lo republicanos tendrán
en su poder un bloqueo de los demócratas
del gobierno en el legislativo y eso
también con la sombra de Donald Trump
planeando presentarse de nuevo a las
elecciones y con el dogmatismo que tiene
en lo republicanos que están cerca de
Trump Pues podría suponer efectivamente
un bloqueo en un momento muy delicado
para el país también con una inflación
récord en varias décadas Ángel su
comentario No simplemente por no retirar
los conceptos del compañero ya en la
gran duda es para mí que Donald Trump
vamos a ver no si va a seguir la Estela
del otro del ex presidente que ya
conocimos o si realmente también va a
mirar a por ejemplo el caso de Brasil o
va a aprender de sus errores o al revés
ver que tiene serias posibilidades de
volverse a presentar y quizás salir
elegido Y si Bueno pues endurecerá su
discurso y seguirá esa Estela que ya que
ya vimos anteriormente
Me parece increíble lo que está pasando
en Estados Unidos los demócratas le
dejaron el discurso de la migración a
los republicanos y los republicanos ni
cortos ni perezosos le han metido tintes
de racismo y de xenofobia estamos
hablando de un partido político que con
una cantidad de candidatos sean
representantes o senadores buscando su
reelección y muchos otros nuevos
consideran que el principal causante de
la debacle económica de los problemas de
seguridad y las dificultades sociales
son los migrantes y se equivocan por
completo porque científicamente está
demostrado que no es así el aporte de la
migración ha sido determinante en
Estados Unidos pero lo que me parece
inconcebibles Santiago es el silencio de
la casa blanca y el silencio de Los
candidatos de los partidos demócratas
por eso estoy seguro que no solamente
van a perder en cámara también van a
perder terreno en senado porque cuando
tú no eres capaz de defender uno de los
principios humanos más importantes y es
garantizar las mejores condiciones para
la migración tema que es fundante del
partido demócrata tú estás entregando
tus banderas políticas al adversario y
la van a capitalizar y no no Fue
suficiente esas visitas que estuvo
haciendo byden a lo largo de esta semana
en los Estados fronterizos estuvo en
Nuevo México si mal no recuerdo fue por
donde comenzó Esa esa gira fronteriza
usted mencionaba que lo más probable es
que el martes do acá anuncios
importantes
primero se va a disolver el comité que
lo está investigando por el asalto al
Capitolio del 6 de enero Este año cuando
se negó a hacer la transición pacífica
en segundo lugar va a detener Las
investigaciones penales y las
investigaciones Fiscales y las
investigaciones administrativas lo cual
le da nuevamente vitalidad a su
candidatura y con un partido republicano
a sus pies con mayoría en las dos
cámaras del congreso de la República
creo que está allanado el camino Muy
Seguramente yo Eva ítem se va a
presentar nuevamente no hay otro
candidato en Estados Unidos hay uno o
dos gobernadores que pintan muy bien
pero creo que va a ser muy difícil de
tener en esta ocasión a Donald Trump
para ir cerrando este tema para
entrarnos ya meternos ya en un tema
mucho más simple y sencillo
Héctor Estados Unidos está empezando a
escribir un capítulo de su historia en
el que tal vez pierde esa fuerza
internacional porque eso es a lo que lo
estaba llevando el presidente Donald
Trump durante sus cuatro años Un poco
aislarse del escenario internacional no
tener tanta relación cercana con Europa
que ha sido su gran Aliado sino como lo
dice su lema América First
sí efectivamente ese aislamiento
internacional
solo beneficia a un país que es a China
de hecho hemos asistido en estos últimos
años en lo que respecta a nuestra región
América Latina de un decrecimiento muy
importante de la influencia de Estados
Unidos sobre los países latinoamericanos
que va a la par de un crecimiento de la
influencia china que no se da solo y
esto es importante en países con
gobierno de izquierda porque de hecho
Bueno tenemos a Uruguay que es un país
con un gobierno de Centro derecha
incluso desafiando al mercosur para para
firmar un tratado de libre comercio con
China y diciendo que evolucionaron
también ha afirmado
pactos y también el presidente
ecuatoriano Guillermo lasso claro Bueno
pues ya me quedan pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa quería
preguntarles por otro hecho importante
de la semana y es la celebración de el
Día de los Muertos o Halloween ustedes
lo celebraron desde qué punto de vista
lo abordan ustedes por ejemplo en
Colombia se celebra mucho más el
Halloween que el Día de Muertos aquí
para conversar un poco de temas de temas
de la cotidianidad Ángeles usted en
España la tradición Cuál es la más
marcada y se disfrazó le pregunto
no me disfracé la verdad es que yo ahora
mismo si viene Acabo de llegar tarde
estoy Yéndome a otro país y he pasado
muchísimo en América Latina he visto qué
manera están distintas sobre todo en
México no de celebrarlo aquí en España
para que os voy a engañar la gente más
joven es la que se disfraza y sale de
copa de noche eh normalmente los
domingos sí se guarda la gente más
tradicional para ella
Ángel es muy joven una máscara casera
Eres muy joven esto claro
soy yo que vivo de saco y corbata y
peinado y maquillado para los noticieros
pero me disfra
vivo en el centro de Málaga que hay
mucho mucho mucho ambiente y la verdad
que me sorprendí de la calidad de los de
los trajes de la juventud de los jóvenes
Darth vader pero ya le digo ese es un
ambiente muy muy festivo excepto por
supuesto el domingo no tiene tanta sala
yturgia o ese ese simbolismo que y
profundidad que tiene en México Claro en
México es muy importante el día de los
muertos es una mezcla entre tradiciones
indígenas y religiosas y el Halloween es
algo más anglosajón más de herencias
celtas y gaélicas ángel por este lado ya
nos comentaba Héctor qué tal celebró
me alegro mucho Primero de de haber
compartido tertulia con el compañero
ángel con el que he compartido
muchísimas aventuras aquí en América
Latina yo no pude celebrar tanto aquí en
Brasil porque era el fin de semana
electoral entonces había mucho trabajo
aquí en Brasil se celebra Bueno aquí en
Brasil la Meca Carnaval Eh pues la gente
se disfraza también para Halloween nos
tomamos una caipiriña en la calle pero
nos fuimos a dormir temprano porque no
daba tiempo para más eso sí eh defender
siempre
la fiesta del día de muertos en México
en la que he tenido la suerte de estar
dos veces me parece bellísima y animo a
todo el que nos estériendo a visitarlo
porque merece muchísimo la pena es una
fiesta que ha empezado a tomar más
fuerza con el paso de los años Jairo yo
confieso que me la pegué me disfracé de
pirata y no recuerdo muy bien como me
fue pero la pasé muy bien naufragó Me
fui una fiesta Fabulosa y no sé porque
yo tengo esa Esa esa ese gusto por los
piratas vaya uno a saber Quizás en otras
vidas como dirían otros fui un pirata la
pasé muy bien Me encanta Halloween lo
que tú decías eso es una costumbre
realmente cristiana Los celtas la
mundializaron como por no decir
globalizar porque en esa época no se
utilizaba ese término pero me llamó
atención en Bogotá nunca en los últimos
20 25 años yo llevo viendo en Bogotá 25
años yo llegué a estudiar en Bogotá
nunca había visto la calle tan vacía con
tan pocos niños con tan poca gente
pidiendo dulces no sé si es un signo
característico en nuestra época no sé si
el tema de inseguridad en Bogotá pues ya
llegó a una situación alarmante en donde
los padres de familia no quieren salir
con sus hijos pero yo me pegue la rumba
Yo también les agradezco Héctor Ángel
Jairo por haber estado con nosotros
haber hecho este análisis para la
audiencia de frases 24 haber compartido
con nosotros aquí en una semana en el
mundo sigan con France 24
[Música]